okay the clock sticked over I'm gonna
get started because I don't on to be the
session that delays everyone which I
probably will be anyway so but let's not
make it because I didn't start on time
I'll start my timer as well um good
morning everyone welcome dense in DC
Sydney my name is William talaq you'll
hear me refer to as Bill I just want to
get that out of the way now causes
confusion and I'm a principal consultant
with rediff I so today what I want to do
is have a look at Glaser it's going to
be a lot of code not me writing too much
hopefully and my snippets are stayed in
place we should be good but it'd be a
slightly opinionated view of blazer and
looking at it through the lens of
front-end web development generally so
if you are doing front-end web
development we are primarily using
frameworks like angular view react or if
you're the only person in the room who
uses polymer which is me that's what
we're doing my only time I use c-sharp
nowadays when I'm doing web development
is when I'm writing the API for the
application I am incredibly frustrated
with JavaScript I find it a constantly
irritating language to work with because
I keep changing things you know who knew
you could use arrow functions I didn't I
do now
but the simple fact is no matter what
you're using whether using typescript or
you've got a framework that's doing all
the you know templating and stuff for
you in the end it all comes down to one
thing
javascript it's the only language that
we currently use within the browser and
I don't think anyone's using VB script
anymore so I'm just I did once just so
if anyone's wondering about that and so
it essentially means that we have that
restriction now is that a good thing or
a bad thing I'm not really I don't
really have an opinion on it but it does
affect maybe people's movement into web
development and working with it so I'm
not going to read this out but Steve
Sanderson who actually created blazer
made this quote which depending on how
you read it is a bit of a battle call so
essentially the saying that why should
we be limited to just JavaScript to work
in the browser and why can't we use
other languages the great thing is that
we have now seen the arrival of
webassembly now webassembly is a as a
standard it's actually supported in all
of the modern browsers and in mobile
browsers and essentially what it does it
provides if you like an intermediate
language that higher-level languages can
compile down to so if you go out on the
web and look around you'll see that
people have used go see double plus
unities being used and the idea and
intent of web assembly is to provide
near native performance in the browser
oh I'm trying to go into web assembly
too much in fact it hurts my brain every
time I read about it so I'm just going
to give you the high-level view but in
essence what happens in web assembly is
that you have a file or an interrupt
created which is compiled to a wesen
file that is then pushes into the
browser's compiler and generates ast
code that's platform specific and then
runs within the browser sandbox so very
much like JavaScript its sandbox within
the browser so there's certain things we
can't do like access files things like
that
and it doesn't kill JavaScript so if
you've been following anyone's blogs
you'll see oh blazer webassembly death
of JavaScript it's not the case they
still need each other where to simply
has to interrupt with JavaScript web
assemblies sandboxed from the browser
api's so you can't directly access any
of those so that's what that does so
what is blazer blazer is and expect it's
essentially experiment we'll cover that
in a second that takes the idea of
writing c-sharp and running in the
browser but unlike say the c double plus
examples it doesn't compile down to west
it takes a different approach Oh my
slides are out of order well let me talk
to this one and I'll just keep going um
so why is it's experimental so the
experimental is microsoft's term for we
don't know if we're going to continue
with it so just be aware of that it's a
great way of it's a great
get-out-of-jail-free card if you need
such a thing the intent is to provide
full stack web development with net via
web assembly though there is now another
version that doesn't require web
assembly and we will if we get time
touch on that one as I said it will work
on all the modern browsers because
webassembly supported it is a spar
framework so blazars been specifically
written to in the same light as angular
and react it is not a generic framework
for running c-sharp so it's not like you
can write little C sharp components and
chuck them in it's about creating web
applications the model it uses and this
is where it differs is that it actually
runs on top of mono wesam now the mono
team have actually created a web version
of the dotnet runtime much like they do
for iOS and Android
and what Blaser does is it actually
compiles your razor views which we'll go
into a second any c-sharp files into a
dll and along with the system assemblies
and any other important packages you
have loads the dll's into the browser
which is kind of scary but that's what
it does a mono then actually manages
running them with the runtime and
handles the Java roon top and accessing
the browser API so that's the difference
in the model c-sharp is not compiled
down to wesam it sits on top of another
layer um the thing they're looking at
with blaze are the key things they're
looking is they essentially want to have
a component model so very much the same
again as what we see in our modern spar
frameworks and libraries it provides
routing I'm not convinced by it yeah
layouts
I'm not going to go into that that's
very much an ASP
not net core kind of thing but you can
use your layouts provides dependency
injection javascript interrupts has an
interesting has Auto build as long as
you're not debugging so but they didn't
seriously you're not gonna be debugging
and this stuff so you know that's kind
of cool you can see debugging has got a
question mark that's a really weird area
at the moment and I love saying this is
this is I've pinched this from someone
else a slide rich and tele sent some
tooling kind of true as long as you
don't run very sharp up so I only
discovered at the beginning of this week
that resharper was screwing up the
intellisense for blaze um so I had to
switch it off tricky stuff if you want
to get started with it there's a website
blazer dotnet you need to install the
core sdk there is a set of CLI dotnet
CLI templates for blazer which you can
install and there's also a Visual Studio
extension cool
so essentially blazer has a number of
project options when you spin up an
we'll have a look at that does the
concept of client only so this is
essentially a static website this is
kind of the cool one I like because it
means you can actually you can put it
into a Mazur storage as a website and
things like that the next one they have
is the asp.net core hosted so
essentially client and server and then
they have bits of code which will then
allow your server application to serve
the client third one is server side only
this is new in Blaser 0.5 this one's
interesting so what they've done is that
rather than relying on web assembly it
renders the code on the server and then
passes the changes up via signal are to
your client the origins of that are
interesting because when they are
developing Blaser they wanted the
capabilities to run it within different
contexts so theoretically we could run
Blaser inside a web worker it hasn't
been done yet but the idea is and the
designs that they've taken this idea and
used it to push out the signal are and
the outcome of
is that apparently they are now going to
change the name to razor components and
in 2019 with asp.net core preview that
will be part of it so we'll now have
this marketing they've got in and
changed the name of it but that's the
server-side thing I'm not a big fan of
it
it makes your application lightweight
but where it becomes I think problematic
as soon as you your internet goes flaky
your page is not going to display and
your JavaScript doesn't run either which
could be a problem okay so um
essentially for the most of this talk
I'm going to be in Visual Studio I just
as I tweeted it this morning I killed
three-quarters of my slides because I
just thought this is going to be boring
if I do that so let's jump over what I
want to do is I'm going to go through
some some key aspects of it so we're
going to look at what it's required to
create a component and there's three
options you have we're going to look at
how we use binding and parameters within
it we also quickly look at the
dependency injection because it's not
quite what you think it is and looking
at calling api's and we'll just work our
way through a whole bunch of stuff and
i'll make snide comments as i go so
we'll see how we go okay so simplest
thing is so one of the key parts of this
is that it uses rays of views now I'm
going to be honest with you I haven't
touched asp.net core in terms of doing
web development well I've never have
actually it's be honest I've never used
it I suddenly got into razor views and I
thought what the hell is that I haven't
seen this syntax in ages I just write
API so it's easier so I'm learning I'm
getting there so essentially we want to
find a raise of you you grab it well if
I'm calling them basic component there
won't be a lot of this actually
I should actually I'm gonna go through
this and then I'm gonna take a step back
because I've missed a key point okay so
we get this lovely bit of squiggly stuff
so that's our basic that's a raise of
you we're done we all can go home now it
doesn't quite work that way so
essentially if you're not aware of
raised views it provides a means to
basically put in HTML and inline c-sharp
code so for example if I go and click
that no not twice so essentially this is
all I do I do standard H HTML put some
stuff in there are a couple of things in
here that aren't going to make sense the
moment will cover those very quickly in
a second
and now part of the syntax is as is that
symbol so this is a way we reference
anything in c-sharp but what I really
need here is some functions and that
anything that said within those brackets
is where we put our c-sharp code and if
I'm if I'm telling you stuff you already
know I apologize now in right
so essentially what we've done is we've
set up we've got some properties
interestingly enough if I do this let's
hope this works
I go public that that one
it usually complains it doesn't like
your properties to be public it wants
them to be protected or private just so
you can set up properties that can be
fields it doesn't matter I prefer
properties it's just the way I think and
then what you can see here is that
essentially with this class we we bind
it will discuss binding in a minute to
that property
the default word of bind it gives us
two-way binding and it will bind to the
default property on that item so if it's
a textbox it will bind to the value it's
a checkbox it binds to that select items
that's kind of weird but it does bind to
something that works
I haven't quite worked out out um and
that's it and that's what we do we can
also bind functions so to unclick I can
actually bind a function to actually
handle the onclick event there is
another way of doing this the problem
with this is that if you need to pass in
any kind of parameters so maybe you want
the passing the object that's in a list
you can't do it that way so what you
would actually do I can see if I could
do this you actually do you would write
that you basically write that statement
and then your own method click and you'd
pass a parameter into there so that's
another way of binding to events not my
preferred way and I think this is one of
the things I finding a little funny is
that some of these solutions are messy
they're hard to reason about what you're
doing so basically we can set up a on
click event razor does provide I mean
blaze up to sorry does provide certain
events UI events that we can we can
bring in and you'll see well I'm going
to be doing in a second my point the
problem with those is they don't tell us
a hell of a lot okay they'll tell us
what the event was like it was a click
it will give us client X and by but no
IDs we don't know who who triggered the
event or anything like that and that's
something we'll get into a bit more and
then essentially it runs that's it so if
I save that and actually just do this
let's run the application so that's the
first way so I can write a raise of you
and keep the C sharp within that far the
second way we can do it is that we can
have a razor page razor view and we can
have a base classic and inherit from so
this works as well no I don't want you
to restore anything
we'd like you to get bigger though thank
you and now it's loading and that didn't
work ah I told you no I'm missing I'm
missing one key thing
so once we've created our component oh
we need to go into the pages and I was
lazy and add it in so here's another
thing about components the name you give
your file is the name it uses in terms
of referencing it as a component within
your page can everyone see that good
so unlike say some low bits like polymer
you for example you have to specify what
its component ID is for working in HTML
this will just take your filename and
use that so you've got to be really
careful about your file names might be
problematic and that's it I'll bring up
the sample in a second once I've done
the other ones the next one is this so
what I would do here is I've just got my
basic race of you and then I do an
inherit and then that let's get this out
of the way essentially it's the same
code we saw before but it's in a base
class there's really nothing different
about what we're doing down ok so that's
that's number two now depending on how
you feel that's probably a neater way of
writing so if you if you go in your mind
pretend code behind it will work but it
does use the inheritance and that works
ok the third version and this is the one
I'm sure everyone would really want to
use is that you can actually just use a
straight c-sharp class it has to inherit
from Blaser component explicitly the
raise of views do it implicitly
so you can write this this is really
nice so
but there's a trap the only way you can
actually do this is that you have to
override one of the built-in methods
called build render tree now what does
that generate let's have a look you do
you do not there thank you so this is
really exciting that's what you'd have
to write believe it or not this is
exactly what blazer generates when you
compile it the the build render tree is
looks like this
so if you really really excited about
writing code like this feel free to do
it this way personally I reckon it's
that's this light Wizards where he'll
lies so try not to do that
an interesting side aspect of that
though is that you can actually and you
might see here I've actually got a thing
called render fragments so there's this
idea that we can render fragments of
HTML into our pages you can if you're so
inclined actually generate it
dynamically so I've announced we go put
that in you can do something like that
so the Builder is always accessible from
within your code and if you really felt
like it you could actually generate a
dynamic fragment and you know so you can
make some decisions about how you're
going to format it it's like writing XML
if you ever wrote XML the old days this
is how we did it there there is someone
who was working on F sharp library that
actually tried to get bit more of a
fluid fluent process for doing it but
it's not worth in this so that's it
those are the three ways we can create
components should save them all
let's bring that window I'm just going
to show you something here I'll just
point this out I'm just gonna caveat
myself very quickly sometimes build
freezers at the moment in this but
essentially if I go and do a refresh of
this you'll see that the build started
so that actually makes a development
experience a little bit better as I said
as long as you're not debugging so this
soon as i refresh the page you will go
and rebuild the application for me and
once it's done
they'll load and then if we jump into
creating component oh shoot the
presenter please I've got something
great components
got back up so it up guess what I had
named something wrong so that was the
name of the old version so if I do this
you'll see now this is positive tell me
since you get it makes it a lovely
purple color so think of so you know
it's actually valid savoured run-up well
I wanted to step back to is I haven't
actually showed you what happens when we
actually set up the file what what the
key components in it so I will take a
step back and cover that waiting
load
there were now I've got my three
components they are literally all of the
they're exactly the same the top ones
the Rays of you responds to something
doesn't do anything different and this
one had the dynamic content they all
work so that's it that's how you build a
component interesting thing and because
I might just give over this part is that
a component is a page where the pages
are component if for example I wanted to
I think I've done it here already here
we'll cover this that's the routing if I
want to make a component of page I just
have to put the page attribute on and
provider out and then it becomes a page
so the one in the same any questions
oh yes it's a good question
know what it's actually doing so this is
where this solve this sort of black
magic essentially what it's doing is
that it's compiled into that dll and
Blaser emits it out through mono and it
interrupts essentially out to the to the
Dom okay and nowadays it is because mono
sits on web assembly that's the thing
and you and web assembly has to
interrupt into the browser so yeah so
the mono sits on top of web assembly and
the blade your blazer application sits
on top of mono essentially cool
something are just very quickly so when
we actually originally set up our
project and this is where that it's very
similar to what we already do if we you
know working on the api's it's
essentially has a startup file it's and
and basically you configure it you just
runs the
is that appoints to a class that we want
to start with a nap this piece of string
here just tells it which component to
inject our blazer application in if we
go back then we go and the other thing
you'll have is that in your web route
you have an index.html and what this
will do is I have that statement there
so when blazer starts up I've put the
loading in there and once it's loaded it
injects into that into that point there
it also will by default has a blazer
webassembly Jo so that handles the
bringing all the stuff together and
injects a couple of things time's going
well okay so very quickly I want to
cover binding a bit more because there's
some aspects of that that are kind of
interesting so when you saw it before
did essentially one-way binding means if
I go at property and just put it within
side an HTML element that's one way I
can't do anything I can bind two ways by
using a bind value another one we
actually have is the concept of
parameters so we can actually place per
ammeter zone to our components so we can
pass the values in and that's another
form of binding we can also bind to
specific properties to allow
parent-child binding which is what we're
going to do here so I've got a note to
myself so essentially I just want to
walk through what some of these things
are this is what we've already seen this
is just a private property it's going to
hold some data I've got a property that
I want to display now interesting one
here I've used a thing called markup
string so this came in 5.0 0.50 and
essentially it allows you to inject raw
HTML which is a really safe and you
should always be very confident about
doing something like that because
nothing can go
wrong okay just just thought I should
let you know that another tag you'll see
on the second the other one we got here
is a parameter tag now what the
parameter tag does saying here's a
property I can inject into or set from
my from whether within my page or from
another control and if you forget to add
it you will get confused the other one I
wanted to quickly discuss we've got the
inject so so I take a little bit
dependency injection Blazer allows for
dependency injection it is no different
from what we do in our normal Net
Applications when it's been set up it
actually automatically injects an HTTP
client and a implementation of I URI
helper and we'll see HTTP client in a
second and you can add any classes or
anything you want into that if you want
to get a property in so this is
interesting I don't that way I probably
shouldn't have I can do it this way so I
can do two things I can set a parameter
on on a property and it will inject into
it
I can also go up here fingers crossed
and you can add inject and you say what
was i injecting I'm can remember someone
remind me knockdown service
and you could give it a dummy so you
assign it to a property and I'll do that
automatically interesting note if you
are writing base classes for your raiser
views instead of doing it in line
you can't inject through the constructor
it froze a hissy fit and tells you we
can't do anything so you have to do what
I've done in this piece of code which
are clearly borrowed from somewhere else
you have to decorate a property with the
parameter to get anything injected into
your base class normal c-sharp classes
as you'll see will actually behave
normally and you can inject further
constructor but you just need to be kind
of aware of that so that's what we've
done here and this one's also
interesting so I'll come back to this
because I've put a comment on what the
hell is this but one of the things about
binding from parents is that apparently
you need to have a action which follows
an Amy convection of the property
changed for it to actually for the child
that receives the change so we've got
that what happens then we've got a
parent I'm not gonna code in this I've
simply got a selected item that looks
right which is bound to the select box
and here's another version of binding so
we saw before if I just use bind or bind
to the you know standard HTML elements
key property if I'm binding to a child I
go bind selected so I can actually
specify the property I want to bind to
and then that will feed through so
what's going to happen here is that when
we run it and I change or I select an
item from the list and it goes to the
selected item it will bind to the child
selected property but that's where it
needs an action selection change to
actually work I haven't worked out why
it has to do that but it's probably
something magic going on so
I'm just going to build it
this is the best part about coding life
is waiting for the build to build so all
things being equal I love my optimism I
might want to just refresh them
okay so that's the parent I go in here
and I select somebody from the list
oh I'm feeling very excited now yes I
knew this was gonna happen
no that's got nothing to do with it okay
gotta go and do some doctoring here fine
selected child selected item child one
key thing okay so one thing I haven't
really covered is lifecycles glasses
razor views or razor blades of
components expose a number of lifecycle
elements that you can hook into which is
pretty standard web you have concept of
on in it so when this thing is
initialized is also initialized a sink
so there's synchronous and asynchronous
versions are basically all as these so
for example if you wanted to make a call
out to a web service on the
initialization you would use
initialization they sink and then you
can do your weight on that the other
ones you have on render on after render
and on parameter set so this is a nice
one one parameter set will do is that
when a parameter changes on your
application you can put some code in to
do something which is what the cowboy
was missing before he goes here so
essentially what I've done all I've done
in this is when the parameter changes on
the on the child component it will check
it and then it will then look up will
look up for the appropriate musician in
my secret collection of musicians and
then do a conversion and convert the
markdown in there so save there's a
couple things that this this touches on
as well
I've used the NuGet package so another
part of what made me interested in this
was the ability that we could actually
take and use existing NuGet packages
given that their net standard 2.0 there
is a catch and then incorporate them
into my browser so in this instance I
have there's a you get package markdown
dig which will actually do convert raw
your raw markdown into HTML so I've
actually brought that in and that
becomes part of my application and prove
myself as I said those scary part is
we're actually downloading all these
dll's so my application is back up
fingers crossed I select and I get text
Wow I mean thank you that's it I'm going
now one clap I'm out and so but that's
really cool and these this stuff can see
the problem is it part of it feels kind
of not quite finished there's still a
sense when you're writing it you're
going with that and my case in point is
the fact for that to work that text got
bigger I think it has I had to put this
weird method in here I had well what I
had to do is put a parameter that can
take an action and it had to have that
name I'm not quite sure what's going on
my feeling is is what blaze is doing is
it's it's it's hooking into that and
saying I need an action to actually
trigger for this to work if I took that
out it won't work but I don't know why
yet I know something but you can see
what's it doing and as you can see it's
actually nice and quick once we're up
and running it's fine
the NuGet package thing is interesting
so yes you can actually and that's the
part excited me is that the idea I can
use existing libraries now I've done
something really weird in here
and I'll show you because it's really
interesting is I brought in Siri log
because logging is great even if it's to
the console so here's here's something
about this and this is the problem is
that when you're debugging at the moment
console log is the only thing you've got
most of the time and that's
console.writeline so you can actually
use console.writeline it's the console
is coming back it's cool and Blaser will
actually push that out as well
but I thinking but I want more
information I want to get funky so
literally I've got Siri log and if we
jump into the startup and go up to here
that one program file because it's where
I did it
I wrote a I wrote a serial log sync
pretty pretty basic that will write to
the browser console so now I could and
so that means any class I bring in
externally and it's still if it's using
Siri log and we'll just keep logging out
to the browser so you can do stuff like
that and that's kind of crazy
foolish possibly I don't think I need to
demonstrate that trust me it works
this is something else that we should
probably touch on and I think I had it
I'm if I bring up my application I don't
need to rebuild it
sure one so two things here so that
output at the bottom if I can see that
is an output from an event aargh into
the click method and as you can see it
gives me some information but I don't
know anything about what triggered it
the other thing is I had to do ad to
serialize it into JSON so here's the
thing the communication between web
assembly and the and the browser I think
it was only uses instant strength and
there's something else so you can't pass
you know normally if I'm writing a
normal web application in JavaScript I
can go console.log pass an object and I
get this lovely you know little thing I
can drill into and find out what
properties are won't work all you'd
actually do is get the string
representation of whatever it is you
passed in so if you want to log via this
you have to serialize it put it in and
that's one of those frustrations right
you know if I'm trying to debug
something but if you would need it it's
there so we covered dependency injection
routing very quickly so what actually
happens is that if I've decorated
anything with the at page attribute this
thing kicks off though penalty will
change it and what it does it basically
walks your assembly and finds all the
things I've got that attribute and then
will manage the routing for it they come
out of the box they provide and I'll
show to very quickly you do pages nav
card
they provide a thing called nav link and
essentially that you just you just need
to provide a link to it and it can be
very simple and it will resolve it and
then it generates an anchor out for it
you can also use the URI helper inline
code I've got another example that way
you can actually pass it in again the
part of that route you want in a resolve
it the other thing with routes is you
can pass parameters I'll come back to
that something I want to discuss so if
we looped with my example interrupt I
want that one more interesting you can
actually if you look at the top of this
you can actually provide multiple routes
for a page so for example if you want
your route URL you can do slash but you
also if anyone types in home it will go
to home you can also do it so if you
want to pass a parameter in you can
actually specify it like that and as
long as that parameter is actually I
know ones not there it's actually the
base class
you can do that as long as that
parameter it will then add that
parameter in I'm actually going to jump
to that example because it should be
working so you can also put constraints
on those parameters there is a limit to
it but if you only want to pass an Inc
you can actually specify it as an int
and then it will throw a curly and not
do anything so we go back here yeah that
one get rid of that this will lead me
into looking at the HTTP client I've
just kind of taken a quick detour and
not-being the Internet's workout there
we go so if anyone thinks I've hacked
some API to get to NDC stuff
no I screen scraped and then push it up
into cosmos DB this is fake
so essentially as you can see here these
my route at the top if we look at that
bring it up it's just that now to prove
this actually works to shrink that again
I could do this I haven't tried this
Thursday
the only one problem I found with if you
type the route into the URL reloads
everything so believe it or not that
filtered to only Thursdays so I can pass
the day and as a parameter and then it
gets supplied and then you can much
nicer to do it this way and it loads up
so you can actually use your routing to
to filter stuff and you can do it all on
the one page quickly jump back to that
example here's another point as I
mentioned they have a a URI helper which
you can inject into your service into
your application again I'm using the on
parameters set async now this time I'm
using the async one so it actually calls
out to my service and depending on
whether I've got a day or night will
call either get all or filter by get day
doesn't magic with these loading but
this one here navigate to so you can
also it within your code use the URI
helper to actually work out what the
route is by passing it the piece you
want so in both cases here if I haven't
got anything to field I just want to
navigate back to NDC talks and if I have
got a filter then this is the route I
wanted it so again and I'm still using
all standard c-sharp stuff you know it's
kind of cool so it's not bad my issue
with routing and it's a general thing
with Blaser and security is that i can't
do things like route guards at the
moment if you work in angular you can
actually put you can set up a route and
you can actually put a guard on it
saying you know this should only be
available if you know your names Bob you
can't do that and because it uses
attributes there's really no way to add
anything into that because that tributes
won't take actions for example I tried
it and that kind of bothers me a little
bit because I would like to be able to
lock down a particular page it's the
stuff we normally do if we've got a
business application you don't want your
general users getting into the
administration page
because they'll give themselves a pay
rise and things like that and so that
part to me is missing at the moment
similarly the whole thing around
managing logins and authenticating is
not brilliant someone I do know that
someone has written a blazer JavaScript
Interop for a ad but the problem is it's
actually interrupting through JavaScript
so I'm not convinced that that's the way
we should go it would be better if we
could have a native c-sharp that could
actually handle that properly eventually
they will come up with but that's to me
is the weakness of the rouse at the
moment it's an all-or-nothing thing I
can't I could put the best I could do is
probably put a guard statement at the
beginning and then look something up and
get that sorted okay
I'll very quickly I'm not going to run
the HTTP cuz the time the clock is
ticking so what they've done the
services there we go I'll pick this one
here so what they've done this is a
blazer uses HTTP client it is just your
bog-standard HT to be fine what they've
done is they've written an HTTP message
handler specifically for blazer and what
it does is actually interrupts into
fetch API in the browser it basically
does all the things there they've
written some extension methods so you
can do the jason they've got their own
json deserialize as serializer
hope is they'll get rid of it eventually
but there were some issues of JSON net
and so when we want to call the API it
is no different than what we do in
c-sharp normally and like that part I
really like I like the way I can I don't
have to think about it though middly now
we've got fetch API and JavaScript is a
lot easier than when I was was it XML
Ajax HTTP something there was this
horrible song-and-dance you had to do to
call an API
okay the point i've left which haven't
touched on is Interop whoa
so you at some point you need to talk to
javascript now the interesting and i'll
bring it up and i was gonna mention at
the end the problem I had when I first
started playing with this is I started
thinking like I was working with
JavaScript and that's a trap I and I
think that if you want to work with
blaze that you've got a step away and
start thinking differently I've seen a
lot of examples where people have done
things like implemented a blazer version
of toaster which is what I haven't got a
problem with that but it's JavaScript
interruptin and he call across they'd
Interop is going to take time it would
seem to make more sense to me as a write
a purely c-sharp blazer based toaster
component rather than interact but
because we're so used to using these
libraries you know npm install you know
toaster and bang you've got to step away
from that mindset because you what the
first thing i started doing was writing
all these interrupts and that's that
this is just chewing up time and it's
weird there are things we knew needs and
drop with so the entire browser api is
critical if if you want to use local
storage
you want to use notifications I started
working on implementing indexeddb and
then got bored no well so let's have
actually have a look at what's going on
there so there we go sauce I've cheated
a little I use typescript once I've
worked out how to get it to behave
itself so to use jar to call a
javascript function
you've got the register it in the window
the way that you can do that is
essentially you can whereas I can
actually add it on so while I not what
you normally do is you're basically as
it sent is the essence of essentially
having a namespace you'll say give it a
name and
you add your extension methods into it
as that if I looked at the JavaScript
for that no we don't want to look at
that I forgot webpack Ricky so
essentially the JavaScript methods got
to be registered with the web
application the two examples I've got
here which are interesting is one is the
canonical alert which we'll look at in a
second and the other one is using
geolocation so I can then go and write
essentially my own class to handle
geolocation provider method on it and I
can call that works for promises that's
really nice so if you are returning
promises your.net will respect that and
if we actually looked at the c-sharp
code the trick to doing all of this
stuff is the jeaious runtime current
invoke async takes a value it expects to
return you have to pass it the name so
the essentially the namespace and what
the method is you want to call you can
pass parameters to it it works fine same
with this one here that works so I go
here
so actually what the canonical example
is prompt this is some text and I can
just you know display your load I think
just I'm gonna clear that text and see
if this works something-something
there's a bug you know it doesn't say
anything refresh that
there is a bug in mono at the moment
mono believes the entire world is
running on UTC time which can be
confusing if you live in Australia so
just very quickly if I call date time
from within blazer it's currently 1
o'clock in the morning I didn't I know
you didn't think it was that earlier but
that's the way it rolls around here ok
just be aware of that if you're playing
with this because you don't want to
depend on it hopefully they'll get it
fixed a better version is if I actually
in this one I'm actually going out and
I've essentially called the geolocation
API it's got me the location and then
I've gone and called bin map services to
actually work out where I am which is
not where I am but you know I didn't
check for accuracy the other thing we
can do is we can call dotnet from
JavaScript which is interesting so very
quickly I do have that okay so to do
that there's two ways the first way is
that you have a class you have a static
method on it and you decorate it with
the Jas invoke a ball attribute and
preferably give a name to that method
what I've done here because this seemed
like a really cool thing to do is
generating a hash so and that's all that
code does to actually call it I've done
this a little differently
here I had to put it in here to call it
within your JavaScript you use dotnet
dot invoke method async you need to know
the assembly name and you need the name
of the method and then you pass it a
value the other way you can do this and
I haven't got to
this is you can actually create a dotnet
instance and pass it into the JavaScript
and then call a method on it but again
you do need to know what that method is
so it's not completely brilliant but on
the off-chance you need to call back
into this so this is wired up to that
method if I click it I get a hash value
I win cool
do you need it yes don't laugh I know
that sounds that's kind of the stupid
stuff I would think up at 3 o'clock in
the morning and I did um I haven't tried
to get and the reason I was interested
in it is I was trying to build a
markdown editor and what I wanted to do
is that as you typed the markdown the
the actual markdown display would update
automatically so you just type bang
the problem is currently the the way
Blazer works it doesn't seem to pick up
change so if you hook into the input on
your text area
it fires and Java and Blazer actually
recognizes but your property doesn't get
updated so you have to wait till it
blurs to change it so what I was
thinking is that as I could write a
JavaScript that would hook on to the
input on the text area and then it will
call a dotnet method to return the value
as a change so I was actually thinking
that and but I don't know whether that's
a rabbit hole I particularly want to go
down I'm already down to quite a few and
that's probably the last thing I want to
do okay
we've got seven minutes probably the
last thing I just want to touch on very
quickly one of the things and there's
two instances in here up here you can
have the concept you have a concept of
Blazer library so you can actually
create a library and create components
and the like you know the down here
I've actually written a login container
now this has got some interesting
features of it which I will quickly
touch on one of the things that we you
would probably want to know is how do I
handle raising events it's a question I
ask myself you can't go omit event or
anything like that so what you actually
do is you have to provide an action
parameter on your component that then
can you can then pass in a function
record so in this one here for example
I've got a prat an action or chord login
details which will then if the parent
component has a action associated that
will then get of events over then we can
actually look at that whole thing of
actually using more of a one-way or on
the directional flow for our data
changes and I've got one for cancel the
I'm going to run this up this thing has
a couple of things which are interesting
it has its own style sheet and it has
its own JavaScript this is an instance
where for example because Blazer can't
actually directly communicate with that
element but I want to give focus to the
first element I can write a I can pass
an element into the JavaScript and then
get at the focus and if we looked at
what that was the way we do that is I
want to hook into here I actually set a
ref and I give it a name and what that
will do is that on the property down
here where it says element ref it will
hook that in and then I can pass that
element ref into it the problem with
that the element ref is opaque to blazer
isn't you can't do anything with it
within blaze so it only makes sense when
we pass it through the JavaScript okay
because a couple of things we want to do
that
and that's the that's logging control
now here's some things when you create a
component library and you put any CSS in
or JavaScript it gets embedded as a
resource this is very exciting and if I
bring up f12 yes things we don't want to
see that elements if you look down the
bottom three script inserts
I think it's voluntary why do you ignore
the top one that's that's my other one
for the serial log thing what you
actually see is that it actually
automatically drops those script
references in to your app there is an
interesting problem with that and
especially around CSS that if you create
a CSS in a component you cannot override
it there's nothing I can do the chaff
tried variables I've tried everything
you can't change it so you're going to
get stuck with it the only way you can
do it is and because you can't you you
write a component and you have to put on
a property that can say managed class or
property that you can inject styles into
seems like a lot of work in my opinion
so that's kind of really interesting if
we cancel that and show login but yeah
as you can see I've got the focus on the
the first text box that was the element
change and I really don't need a
password but I will anyway okay very
quickly because we're running out of
time the the other aspect to that is
that you can also grab a reference to
your component and if you've got public
properties on it you can actually call
them so if I went into
bang you know I've lost the page that's
really scary there you go logging an
example so similar kind of thing this is
my login control up here I can grab a
ref for it and I've got login dialog box
and what I can actually do is I've got a
public method on it called show so it's
meant to be show and hide it's a modal
dialog I can then call that method on
that reference cool that's it we've got
three minutes left am I going to push it
to there to the answer degree we've
discussed suicide only so where do we
stand
I was really dubious about this one I
started working with it
there was I've literally had a cognitive
clash between I've worked an angular
I've worked in polymer and you know I
kind of got that in my head it works and
then I started writing this now could
have been that the whole raise the
syntax is a little freaking and it was
the more I've done it the more I'm
thinking this actually could be feasible
where I think they've got weaknesses
around things like we don't you know
it's not like a web component there
isn't a shadow Dom I can't hide my
stylesheet so those things are kind of
weaknesses to me you can actually inject
style directly into your component I
didn't find out what it did but it will
put it into it because it doesn't care
it just writes that stuff out they have
a concept where I can I can put child
components in so but it has to be a
child content so we don't have things
like slots so if I wanted to make like a
card thing and I want to be able to
inject a title slot and stuff I can't do
that so you've got to create separate
things I actually found that not having
to worry about how web pack was running
and stuff was kind of nice I just
compiled and it works this is good so
it's still it has potential
I suspect that Microsoft are actually
going to look and actually be able to
compile c-sharp down to Azzam at some
point so it's hard to tell where this
will go there the road map is 2 released
6 in September the Dinks and monthly
updates and as I mentioned before the
Razr components
there are actually some really good
surprisingly the community around this
is really taking off so a lot of people
have written examples people have
written a new drop for the local storage
there's variations on Redux and flux so
we can implement that model in it so
it's a lot going on it's reasonably easy
to pick up it just takes a little bit
more time to deal with the nuances of it
because it's really about changing your
mindset that's about it I think we're
finished are there any questions Enders
her hand at the back ah that was a
really popular one you know what you
can't because jobs groups aid actually
critical to the whole interrupts process
so the thing with webassembly and this
is they live together I think it's more
around the fact that there are still a
lot of developers who aren't comfortable
writing JavaScript they're probably X
Silverlight developers so they're if
you're really cut I'd look I'm going to
be frank I love writing c-sharp I think
in c-sharp I think a lot better in
c-sharp than I do in JavaScript
JavaScript bums I still have to use a
dictionary to remember a word on you
know every time I have to use a promise
I get confused and so to me it's a more
natural language to writing some of the
other things you'll see we didn't really
touch on it if you've got a client and
server app and I have basically all my
data models as shared library I can use
them across both so I'm not having to
normally if we we have our API and I've
got you know say user model and it's got
first name last name blah blah blah on
the client-side
I think I've got to write a class to
handle it or I've just got to remember
what it is and it comes in as a JSON
object what this will what you can do in
blazes I can have my user class in
c-sharp and then basically imported into
the client and use it there as well and
makes it a lot easier
I think eliminating duplicate code
managing change across those things I
mean is it is it is it does it is it a
great reason to jump not necessarily but
is it more convenient could be any other
questions no when it stops being
experimental you know is so it might end
up being like a you know one of those
planes that crash those test planes and
obtain Steve Sanderson is really
dedicated to it the the it's open source
there are a lot of people contributing
to it I think once they shake out some
of the bugs and debugging is a big one
at the moment the fact that the
debugging experience is utterly awful is
a problem because it you know and then I
think it's a big stopper I think the the
the other thing is I haven't actually
looked at testing yet I've looked at
their code they use a how they testing
component are using things like headless
browsers and stuff I haven't looked at
that testing experience I think there's
still a few things they need to do I
find a fact that I can't directly access
an element from within blaze so it's a
little bit a feat because sometimes you
just need to to do that so I it's hard
to say but there's a reasonably strong
community around it anything else
no don't dusted sold thank you very much
for coming I appreciate the time